[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> Hi, I'm Julia, and I'm going to be on a
panel debate about female
genital mutilation.
It's a really complex issue.
It's a human rights cause.
And the YouTube community voted for me to
go to Davos to have this
debate.
The debate will be facilitated by Nick Kristof,
who's an award-winning
journalist for the New York Times as well
as other experts and leaders
on the panel.
And what we want is for the community to pose
questions.
So please go to YouTube.com/Davos and either
video or text in your
questions.
Also, favorite the ones that you like the
best.
We'll be picking the favorite questions and
be putting them to the
panel, so please submit a question now.
The deadline is Saturday, the 30th of January.
And we really look forward to answering them
live at Davos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]